we're going to be talking about why so
many of your favorite movies are
secretly conservative
just want to give a shout out to our
friends over at raycon for sponsoring
this video you want the best pair of
wireless earbuds on the market raycons
are the ones
hi i'm john krasinski and i'm hosting
snl with machine gun kelly
big week huge week but no pressure
though you better be funny
[Music]
who doesn't love john krasinski it makes
sense there's lots of love about john
krasinski people love the office
everybody loves jim and of course he
made a delightful little at-home news
show that went viral during the pandemic
he's the type of dude that seems to
resonate with americans of all types i
think one of the reasons why people like
him is because of the not so obvious
conservative values
in some of his movies particularly in a
quiet place and that got me thinking
about some other hollywood projects that
have some kind of sneaky
under the radar conservative qualities
that happen to be widely celebrated
by the left unintentionally i'm going to
show you what i mean with a few really
recent movies the endings of these
movies
are the parts that best exemplify the
values so i'm just warning you now these
are big spoilers for all of the movies
we're about to discuss
if you don't want to know what happens
jump ahead to the next film that you've
already seen or jump
all the way ahead to the part where i
tell you why so many movies generally
are conservative even though they don't
mean to be let's start with a quiet
place a quiet place was released to
overwhelmingly positive reviews john de
four from hollywood reporter said quote
scenes of what passes for ordinary life
let the screenplay focus on mom and
dad's attempts to educate their son and
daughter while never letting them forget
how dangerous their lives are
one thinks of what we hear from parents
of black boys raising them to be normal
and happy but hyper-vigilant
about the way they are perceived by
others that's a pretty
wild and deep read right there from the
hollywood reporter this is a black thing
isn't it
the box office on this movie enormous
it's a very low budget film
it made 340 million bucks at the box
office numbers that are not going to be
paralleled in the in the new post
covered era for those who haven't seen
the movie there's a family that has to
live in silence because there are these
mysterious aliens that hunt by sound
so any sound draws the aliens knowing
that even the slightest whisper or
footstep can bring death
evelyn and lee those are the parents are
determined to find a way to protect
their kids while desperately searching
for a way to fight back
the very beginning of the film this
isn't really a spoiler it's literally in
the first three minutes of the film
they have a very young child they they
are trying to walk into town
to get food in this post-apocalyptic era
and the little kid
basically gets eaten by an alien so now
mom and dad have to decide are they
gonna have more kids and they do they
get pregnant they decide to have
the kid despite the fact that it puts
everybody at risk there was some flack
out there
for emily blunt's character being with
child in a horror apocalyptic setting
but those reactions miss
the actual deeply profound nature of the
story the entire concept of the film
is rooted in the risk that is going to
take place in the last third of the film
when mom actually has the baby
this is about the idea that even when
you have a pretty good reason not to
have a kid you should still
have a kid and take life-altering risk
in order
to have that kid so unintentionally the
movie's incredibly pro-life okay but
that is not the only mainstream
hollywood film that has received all
sorts of critical plaudits and is
actually pretty conservative
hey how about seoul so soul just came
out is the new jamie fox pixar movie
the film is about a new york jazz
pianist named joe he suddenly finds
himself trapped in a strange land
between earth
and the afterlife when he falls down a
manhole and apparently dies
in trying to hold back his own death
with whatever it takes he ends up
stumbling into the great before
in a magical reinterpretation of life
beyond earth there is a system where
unborn souls
exist these unborn souls have value
they've existed well before
childbirth this is where new souls get
their personalities
quirks and interest before they go to
earth they're given a spark
which is a passion as the final touch
and then they are placed into human
bodies
life exists both before and after life
and before a child is born
there is life and before and after
people die there's like these are
extremely religious
and conservative concepts there's no way
to watch soul and go okay yeah and then
if you believe that the soul is
implanted
in the in the body of the fetus from
conception which presumably is what's
happening that
if you believe that's what's happening
that you should go ahead and have an
abortion it's a very pro-life film
people who have made it i'm not sure
realize that but it just is
a rival that's another film that
received overwhelmingly positive reviews
myra reinstein from us weekly wrote the
sci-fi thriller not only subverts
expectations in brilliant ways
it explores deeply felt themes of life
loss and love
the box office on arrival 200 million
dollars at the box office eight academy
award nominations and one win
so the academy is very much into
wokeness right the academy
loves the woke so why exactly did they
love this film why did so many people
love this film on the left that makes no
sense when you actually look at the
theme
of the film so for those who missed it
the film follows a linguistics professor
named louise banks she works with the
military to communicate with alien life
forms after mysterious spacecraft appear
around the world
with nations on the verge of global war
banks and her crew are racing against
time to find a way to communicate
with the extraterrestrials it's a really
sophisticated and interesting film now
during the film we keep seeing
what we think are flashbacks of louise
with her daughter right from birth
through a short childhood
and up until her daughter dies at a
young age from a fatal disease
and you think that these are flashbacks
that louise because she has experienced
this pain
she now has the capacity to speak to the
aliens in a different way and see the
world
in a different way okay but that's not
actually what happens in the film those
are flash forwards
that because louise is communicating
with the aliens and the aliens have the
capacity to see into the future
louise knows throughout the process that
she is going to have a child
and that the child is going to die at an
early age and she knows that if she gets
together with
uh this other guy working with her was
played by jeremy renner that
she's going to have this kid this kid is
going to live suffer and then die
and she decides to go through with it
anyway i have not seen a more pro-life
message in any movie because one of the
great themes of the pro-choice movement
is
life is not worth living if you are
going to have a kid who is going to have
some sort of terrible disease
or if you know that the kid's life is
going to be cut short in any way or the
kid's going to suffer in any way
it's an inherently pro-life film i mean
this is a mother making the decision to
have a child and give the child the gift
of life knowing that suffering for her
and her family is going to follow
pretty pro-life if you could see your
whole life from start to finish
would you change things okay finally the
florida project
so the florida project is not as openly
conservative as some of these other
films now again none of the people who
made these other films would acknowledge
that these films are conservative they
just are again a film with an academy
award nomination a golden globe
nomination
and reviews like this one from helen
o'hara quote vibrant and brimming with
vitality this is empathic
toward its subjects but fiercely
critical of the system that victimizes
them
that's actually not what the movie is
about director sean baker was also
behind the transgender film tangerine
which followed a sex worker on the hunt
for
his slashers cheating boyfriend who's
also her pimp so
obviously this is not a conservative
person the florida project follows a
woman named haley
who lives with her six-year-old daughter
mooney in a motel catered to the walt
disney world tourists outside orlando
florida
haley survives largely on welfare she
has pretty much no respect for other
people especially people who cross her
she has an attitude she's passed on
to mooney i failed as a mother monie you
disgrace
me mooney is mischievous she influences
her friends into tricking strangers into
giving her money
she talks back to the adults she curses
these are all things learned from her
mom and then willem dafoe
plays the sort of landlord at the motel
who ends up trying to act as sort of a
quasi-father figure and protect mooney
the movie is certainly not meant to be a
conservative rip on the
need for fathers in the home and the
need for traditional values and social
fabric
but unfortunately for him that's kind of
what the movie is he may be trying to be
a critique of capitalism and misses
and maybe trying to be a critique of how
we treat the impoverished in our society
it misses what the film really is about
in the end
is how individual bad choices have
ramifications for children
and that when you have children you have
to start making better decisions because
when you take
all of the social institutions and
fabric away from children
their life is essentially over they're
living in a dream world
in which they cannot escape the
nightmare right this is the movie's
basically about the fallout of having
kids without fathers in the home
it's about the the fallout from not
acting well even if you do have
responsibilities to your own child
that when you don't have traditional
family values things fall apart
incredibly quickly the film was well
regarded by the critics williamspo
actually got a nomination for best actor
at the golden globes and the academy
awards and the film is good
the film also happens to be a complete
referendum on bad behavior
by parents who don't think beyond the
next five seconds we're talking movies
here and if you want to watch
movies with the best sound possible
here's what you need
ray cons check these babies out so
they are beautiful they come in this
nice case you open them up
you pop them in your ears and you're
ready to go
boom done behold
behold the magic they have now synced
raycon
disrupting the electronics industry by
designing premium wireless audio for
half the price
without compromising they're doing
things differently than other brands out
there from the way they design the
products the way they price them
raycon prioritizes customer experience
from start to finish
raycon offers their wireless earbuds in
a range of fun colors and patterns
check these look at that blue magical
with a variety
of fit options these ones fit my ear
perfectly because i had already pre-fit
them
no dangling wires no stems i mean i look
amazing do i not you can look just as
amazing the company was co-founded by
ray j celebrities like snoop dogg mike
tyson obsessed with raycon's
i am too so that's pretty wide variety
right there plus raycon has a 45 day
free return policy
raycon earbuds give you six hours of
playtime seamless bluetooth pairing more
bass
more compact design for a comfortable
noise isolating fit whether you're
taking up that new hobby or you just
want to make your day-to-day
a little more comfortable or you want to
watch great movies with excellent
earbuds raycons those are the perfect
way to bring premium audio to everything
you do so
click the link in the description box or
go to buyrecon.com
shapiro yt by rakon.com shapiro yt
to get 15 off your recon purchase
there are lots of films that we've not
discussed here that have even more
openly conservative
themes right dark knight rises is an
obvious one lord of the rings films are
very conservative
stalin is very conservative i can't
believe that any of the people who made
those films are actually openly
conservative they're not so why do
filmmakers in hollywood keep making
films with conservative themes that
contradict their actual political
ideology
and why do liberals in hollywood keep
responding to the conservative themes
well here is the thing
when you look at the structure of story
story is inherently bent toward
conservatism why
because it has to contrast a virtue with
non-virtue
so start with the aristotelian idea of
the tragic hero the tragic hero who's
a feature in nearly every piece of
content for thousands of years
is a person a virtue who has a tragic
flaw the tragic flaw is exploited and
the hero falls
the basic idea there is a couple of
things one you have a person who
actually is virtuous right there is a
difference between acting virtuously
and not acting virtuously then the hero
has a flaw in his virtue
that flaw leads to his downfall because
the world is a
fair and just place in which flaws
tragic as they may be
end up condemning and consigning people
to bad fates
right so their inherent values and story
okay more colloquially
and more more commonly people in the
entertainment industry tend to circulate
around the hero's journey by joseph
campbell
wrote a book called the hero with a
thousand faces in which he laid out what
he thought was sort of the mythic
structure
and this is present in nearly every film
the one that most famously
it is present in is star wars right the
entire star wars
episode four is rooted in the hero's
journey there are a bunch of steps along
this way that are inherently
conservative again
in order to have heroes you have to have
villains and have heroes and villains
you have to have values so the idea
of a moral relativism in which there is
no right and there is no wrong and we
have to understand
every side of the story and every side
of the story inherently is
like that is boring nobody's all that
interested in it and it doesn't work on
film
then there is the the problem in in all
storytelling of free will
it turns out that the most boring type
of story is one in which you know what
is going to happen
at the end of the story and in fact it
is going to happen no matter what the
hero does because the hero is not in
control
one of the key elements of the hero's
journey is that the hero has to take
control of his own life right he has a
hero's journey a hero's arc in which he
goes from somebody who doesn't want to
be involved
to somebody who not only is thrust into
involvement but becomes the active
participants
in his own story that person is going to
have to overcome obstacles if the
obstacles are overcome for him he's not
the hero
if the hero is just faced with a villain
and then the villain collapses because
other people from society force that
person to back down the hero's not a
hero
the hero is now a passive participant in
their own story every movie that you see
that has a hero overcoming obstacles
that is about a person who is acting
with
some form of durability and integrity in
the world
and these are all conservative values
they do not hold up to to left-wing
scrutiny in fact
even the most left-wing films you've
seen are built along these lines
even ones that are overtly left-wing are
built along the lines of there is some
oppressor who is trying to stop the hero
from being free
and now the hero must stand up for
himself and or
for somebody else they have to stand up
for somebody else now
there can be left-wing ideas that are
pushed using this sort of conservative
formula you see this in film
all the time but if you're trying to
tell an apolitical film one that is
openly left wing very often you'll see
these sort of conservative messages
seeping in so to go back to the original
examples
if you're looking at a quiet place the
challenge of this family
is to survive and to propagate to the
next generation
you have to protect them
promise me you will protect them
if mom decided to have an abortion she
and dad are not the heroes anymore
she and dad are just victims of the
situation right if you go back to
arrival
if the heroine of the story knows that
she is going to
have a child the child is going to
suffer and die but she decides not to go
through with it
then she's no longer the heroine of the
story
she's just somebody who's a victim of
circumstance it is the challenges in
life that cause us to rise above the
challenges
in life right that is the power of the
myth that is the power of the story
and to do so with virtue right so all of
that has to be upheld in in story
structure
and that's why you see so many films
that are purportedly left-wing that
actually are not as left-wing as the
creators
would want them to be and if they ever
figured this out then they would be a
lot less insulting about conservatism
considering that virtually all of the
hallmarks of the films that they make
are rooted in conservative ideas
about the world about morality about
decency
and about self-control and free will i
want to know what you guys think
what are some of the other films that
you've seen that you think are actually
kind of secretly conservative but the
people don't even know they are making
conservative
films i know there are a lot of you out
there with ideas leave them in the
comments below we'd love to hear your
recommendations did you know that every
like on this video creates one
additional leftist tier don't ask me why
that's called science to take advantage
of this amazing opportunity
hit the like button